hi everybody my name is Rahul Kumar and
I'll be talking about Sanka which is
doing a I assisted DevOps so the idea
for Sankey is quite simple at heart we
want to learn various behaviors and
patterns that developers and engineers
practice every single day of their life
for instance a lot of patterns may exist
on the development side of things where
certain pull requests are being created
in a regular manner certain code reviews
are being done in a very regular and
organized manner similarly we can also
grab information and data from the build
and test stage of a pipeline from the
release and post deployment stages and
aggregate all of this into a holistic
view to provide actionable
recommendations today what I'm going to
do is I'm going to focus only on the
development side of things and I'll show
you how Sankey operates on github so
essentially I'm on github and I have
forked the Microsoft terminal repository
into my account for doing this demo and
I'm creating a new poll request which is
a code change that I've authored the
branch that I'm going to use is the
faculty summit demo branch which is what
was curated for this particular
experience here today there are three
files that have been changed there are
three total commits that were made when
I create this new pull request I can
have a title here which is creating a
new function for testing there is a pull
request template which I can potentially
also fill out I choose to just go with
the default when I create this pull
request github will actually send a
message to Sankey saying I've got a new
pull request that was created in this
particular repository and just to
confirm that my files that have changed
yes I have three files that have changed
I have a few commits inside here as well
and then I have my conversation which is
where I'm seeing I'm looking at updates
that are happening when Sankey or
anybody else processes this pull request
in a social experience
so just to show you what the changes
look or what the comments look like from
Sankey at some point thank you we'll
come in and say that it has identified
two reviewers which is Zack G - MSFT and
then Carlos is amaura as the most
appropriate reviewers for this pull
request that's because the files that
are being changed in this pull request
are probably either owned by these
individuals these developers or they are
highly edited and reviewed by these
particular developers in this repository
so Sankey has understood that certain
developers have 1/10 have a certain
tendency of being experts in different
areas of the source code or they have an
expertise in reviewing these areas and
on top of that saying he's also capable
of load balancing the review load
amongst all the developers in a
repository so that was the first
suggestion the second suggestion that
was made is based on the files that have
changed we also recommend that you
change the term control dot H file and
that's because one of the files that's
being changed is the term control dot
CPP file and the header the dot H and
the dot CPP file have a really really
strong association with each other and
based on past commits in this repository
Sankey has with a certain level of
confidence determined if you're changing
one of these files the other one should
probably be changed as well imagine all
the configuration files you have or all
the settings files you have they need to
be changed as well one single cluster
together right and that's what Sankey is
telling us here
lastly Sankey's saying oh based on the
contents of this change I'm going to
label this change as a bug fix and as
test work and that's because I was
creating new a new function for doing
some testing and I was probably fixing
something in the process as well this is
a way for saying to classify the change
which in return is a signal to
repository owners to see which way
they're trending is their repository
experiencing a lot of bug fixes is it
experiencing a lot of feature work we
have 8 such decorations that we can
perform for the label
and get a sense of what are the next
steps as a repository owner looking at
these labels you can say okay I now know
what what is happening with my developer
body and how can I move it forward in a
particular direction or should I be
changing focus right these are examples
of Sankey giving you an actual
recommendation our suggestion if you
will to improve the development
experience we also do things which are
on the on the right side we can minimize
tests we can create automatic test plans
based on past results of the testing
that has been performed against your
repository and then lastly we can also
do post deployment analysis to
understand whether there's a single
metric that's being affected by certain
types of changes in your in your
repository so overall to closeout Sankey
uses data from various different parts
of the of the DevOps lifecycle uses
lightweight machine learning methods and
creates actionable suggestions to
improve the developer lifecycle and
experience at the end of the day thank
you